cosa mai primo è benvenuta questo nuovo
video io sono su un cimelio del gaming
siamo su youtube air slide due hanno
fatto due ragazze sco hanno fatto di
tool per 62 schiaccia subito per
continuare il nostro non troppo contento
di vedere che cacchiano fatto perché
siccome youtuber saif uno era un po
trascino vedo perchè non debbano farlo
ci credo ce l'avevo suo computer io
veramente vorrei capire che ha fatto il
2 di youtube versly fraga ci sono anche
i nano l'ip bellissimo va bene allora
parte le musiche che spero non siano
completati a questo punto visto che
sanno che lo registrano youtube verso
gioco facciamo nuova partita sono molto
curioso di vedere che cosa hanno fatto
youtubers live 2 rispetto al primo
appena l'ho vista duomo non lo posso
averlo fatto sul serio
c'è anche la iii trova bene come si
diventa youtubers dalla saletta la
cameretta
ok
ma cos'è sta roba
io dico perso del mondo defant mondo
fantasy hai vinto ah ok a un gioco vero
apr congratulazioni 6 prima aver
completato youtubers light un
esperimento sociale per scoprirlo
youtuber più promettente di coppa che
sarà catturato la nostra attenzione per
questo estremamente di darti il
biglietto d'oro per poter venire a
vivere a youtube city la città dove
risiedono gli youtuber migliori il luogo
perfetto per costruire alto carriera e
diventare qualcuno sa centrali video
sarebbe felice di farti l'aquila e
questa è la vittoria
certo il mio sogno
no non mi vedi che sto fremendo ma se io
voglio diventare uno youtuber di beauty
io faccio il porto dove voglio andare al
porto aiutarono verdi beauty
[Musica]
farm usare i tocchi c'erano subito a
preparare il suo appartamento vestiti
come un vero youtuber
[Musica]
guarda qua a me lo vuoi dire vestiti
come rame tipologia corpo devo fare me
stesso appena la prima cibo non è non
c'è la canalizzazione di sky
azzurro anche no dai cos'è ma così
perché la cicatrice di harry potter a me
sembra proprio io quando non ho voglia
di vestirmi c'è sempre
scarpe nel tradito ma per cortesia ma
per cortesia lo youtuber in ciabatte va
bene conferma bastano falsi si voglio
fare l'olio giù per in infradito voglio
avere successo con il fallito se è un
successo le infradito perché proprio
sono talentuoso cioè la grafica dei
pokémon la grafica di proprio questo
giorno è vero ea non è ancora forte
l'alcol iscritto per oggi è a pavia che
mi stai parlando senza dirmi niente
benvenuto a youtube city d'ora in avanti
questa salato lo a casa non è molto
grande ma non preoccuparti presto potrai
decorarle migliorata come preferisci
avrei gestito soldi sulle sulle cuffie
surreal 9 bellissimo neanche iniziare
così figo
apri pacco cos'è una camera che ti segue
ti pongo pro portati a giampiero caso
non drone cam assistente personale per
la registrazione giampiero gianpiero per
favore da mio nome giampiero
dai capelli dai giampiero caricamento
verso
giampiero
superlativo bimbi pensi mi di rispondere
cosi jean è stato un piacere più per
registrati aiutarti notai avere bisogno
perfetto per registrare i video spiega
giampiero prendete necessario creare
anche lei youtube la piattaforma
migliore dove i creatori di contenuti
pubblicano i propri video accesso a
youtube
il tuo nome fa ei ristoratori gtv dai
facciamo uguale celi la data del tuo
compleanno
77 primavera non 7 aprile 7 primave
primavera va bene dei pip che non
interessante fa vj grazie ti andrebbe di
mettervi subito alla prova solo tentato
questo è un punto di registrazione sarà
regista di video trova altri punti
permettono sparsi per la città beep beep
usa al punto di nascita del freddo più a
flog di presentazione il canale io ti
registrerò uguale per iniziare il video
saluti timidamente ricche e il tricarico
energia a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono poi j e vi
ringrazio per la mia pessima battuta
benissimo benissimo
percepisce la presenza paranormale hai
un attacco di risata questo guarda
faccio come facevo io all'inizio facevo
facciamo queste cose io all'inizio
giampiero si sta scaricando sempre
sempre che di il video che vi agli
iscritti chiudi il video è ragazzi
giampiero e scarico belle ragazze che
cosa le dense catturate clip da quello
devo montare io giampiero cosa fai tu
spiega ma non l'ho montato registrato
più ad hoc completando molti tool video
jean dei pip ben fatto gli allora
dobbiamo pubblicare video su youtube ma
prima diavoli ritocchino col tuo
computer soprattutto io che cazz falso
gianpi a niente resistere basta versai
dai un cane camera un peso alla versione
camera vendita quindi e giampiero non è
un giampiero 2.0 man gianpiero 0.5 che
fa meno
a blog lo scopo è quello di ottenere più
punti possibili inoltre se riesce a
collegare inizio la fine del video tiene
un punto bonus succulento il futuro
qualora epici co più punti di rendering
potrai comprare degli effetti video da
usare tecniche
ora lasciamo il genio creativo scatena
guarda come sono creativo è
142 mamma mia ragazzi che youtube c'è
una frase click day
dalle geniali per questo nome né dai
pubblica voglio questo questi
tre like ei tre like metti light anche
tu
ma che cazzo tanti altri rivali
videogiochi precisa è questo l'invito di
galles in atmosfera gaming per fortuna
aveva una pronta posizionare la donna è
una pronta a via ma come mai i regali
tutte ste cose per chi sei non una
pronta e dove ho detto qua
aggiungi mobili nuovo spazio di lavoro
postazione da gaming che bella compra
che è una merda non ammetto qua la
vorrei mettere il codice letto dietro
più figo ma non lo posso mettere posso
mettere solo qua ok perfetto e sistemata
ora non ti sono altro che una console è
un gioco molti youtuber poligono tutti i
videogiochi
va bene ma è negozi di videogiochi
giocatore 1 e parla completi che reti
dalla tutto o penisola dove sul telefono
rama per la città va bene ciao giampiero
giampiero incredibile ti fa anche da
eco eco anche google maps parla con
player ma mi segue comunque lui ciao
ragazzi facciamo un bel video dove io vi
do fastidio ammette giocata palla non so
io vorrei fare di virus ecco un gatto
che in trend accarezza riprendimi
giampiero riprendimi riprendimi jean
ribelli di metterci un gatto vicino a
mio padre jean pieni di riprendere
mentre i carezzi gatti riprendimi 6
dormendo che facciamo le news non
guardava che the youtuber che tempismo è
che poi è un casino ed aisha con chi
parlò sun che parla fa ma che parla a
fare che parla a fare eccolo qua player
one giocatore ora il giocatore 23 sul
centro pokémon madonna la zia come stai
tutti i videogiochi armonie del nucleo
come si chiamava quello del the key of
war costa 96 monete va bene investiamo
investiamo investiamo investiamo a
questi sono 50 per cento rainbows i
gilet hardware ed nucleus non ce l'ho
soldi palermo nel nucleo deve uscire
ciao arrivederci
vado a registrare kollhoff diego perché
si chiama marmone doc di utility quel
gioco ho comprato da registrare quello
tanto la maglietta nt cv che sarebbe
youtube city university va bene regis
migliora spazio console spaccio un solo
uno che lo fai 9 giocare io voglio
spazio gioco 10 che cazzo vuol dire no
voglio giocavo io ci siamo vi fabi
registrano video su come si chiama armor
ed nuclei usa non amo le lucrose era
quello di scontro contro e quello sono
pirla allora migliora io non so cosa
devo migliorare voglio giocare basta c'è
una scusa edita video cosa deve dita non
ho fatto niente giampiero che cazzo fai
tutto il giorno e montava rafa yobe ma
non è che devo trovare uno spazio in
giro per la città dove registrare perché
se comunque va in giro mentre che c'è
sempre gente accampata fuori da casa non
è un pisciatoio per cani casa mia e non
devo dire ai ragazzi installato anche in
st wright che sarebbe mai bicchia
fatiche ciccio blair madonna mai
un'influenza e allora vendute al play
con sé una è una fiera bellezze tipo poi
vieni giù
di quel blitz con comunque anni andiamo
posso pubblicare una foto
belli sia un cambio cosa
ma non ho anche fatto di merci che foto
di merda tendenze catturate casa è certo
ciclo strato di ghiaccio il cappotto di
merda a casa che bello gianpiero scarico
perfetto uguale al mio profilo di vista
nella stessa rotta e allora interagisci
migliora di consiglio registra video
vedi che possano di stabilità andò a
dormire
alla consolle
ma io c'ero le console dove piazzare
ancora in giro
raggiungi mobili a eccoli lo zaino nero
che la la playstation studio one o nei
play studio swan e la metto che ne
trovano posto mettono sopra il comodino
o 28 per terra e non c'è il como di noi
ammette per terra posiziona e poi posso
ancora mette al cielo 2d dei key of war
1 l'avevo già comprato porco demonio
mentre un altro lo posso vendere
seleziona ok e lo posso giocare le sue
interagisci registra video trovano di
manifesti con anziani di play con e
scatto di una foto eco intaccata perché
va dalla fiera prima andiamo alla fiera
mi pensi al video normale prima registra
un peso normale un blog di grava la
fiera the key of war non lo posso
registrare perché non me lo fa scarica
commento questo qua ciao ragazzi di
registrare e saluti timidamente nelle di
ragazzi percepisce la presenza faranno
narrati abbandoni da solo questa mia
battuta è pessima ma tutte pessime
migazzi tuoi follower per il supporto e
rischi ti lasci scappare un water park
bene per fermare
chiudi il video o chiede allestiti
ragazzi posso fermare video si che poi
ok ciao
ma come cazzo pensano nesi faccio
youtube è roba incredibile e poi do
montarlo fammi montare no ho comprato la
console ma non so come sia ad si avvia
aiuto
8 like dove l'hai 9 like sono più famoso
sì sì ho comprato la somma non solo vi
si avvia aiuto madre va da fuoco
bellissimo vero sto male ragazzi direi
che posso concludere qui il video perché
giampiero si sta scaricando quindi
iscrivetevi al canale mettete un bel mi
piace giampiero adesso monterà il video
con con le formine temi del peso dovrei
sapere se volete un episodio di
youtubers light ma per me del liceo
quindi pensato lo farò come sempre se vi
sia piaciuto a ciò che tu mi piaci
schede al canale è noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video seguitemi anche su
installa iv
c al prossimo video bei ragazzi
[Musica]